on top of that the first female
millionaire was in the late 1800s now
everyone will say oh oh well Pearl but
there are exceptions like most
millionaires were men most people
weren't millionaires you know how hard
it is to become a millionaire even today
so isn't it that kind of evidence that
women actually could do things if they
wanted even without the right to vote
and the funny thing is there was a far
bigger anti-suffrage movement than a
suffrage movement there were hundreds of
thousands of women I imagine them like
myself that just came forward and signed
petitions saying no women should not
have the right to vote because evil
women get into power and think they're
equal to men when they are not and they
will try to break down the family